are you considering buying this month's
Empire you should because your favorite
Merc with the mouth hijack the entire
editorial staff and made the issue is
very own that's right empires editors
are locked in my crawlspace desperately
longing for the sweet release of death
that left me time to fill these pages
with whatever I wanted meaning plenty of
simple do-it-yourself recipes involving
Cornish game hen freshly pitted Greek
olives locally purchase deli meats and
wolf semen not to mention explicit
pictures of me the ever-loving out of a
weeping kevin sorbo on a bed of hot
brown Hercules pantaloons and that's not
even the centerfold which is
wall-to-wall Evelyn's ferret chasing
leprechauns and a full transcript of at
least three of my worst films you get
all of this set to my favorite country
tune you're crying hard and I'm hard
because you're crying purchase Empire
today and you'll receive a free of
charge three high-ranking stitches and
the complete sexual histories of several
of the world's most trusted news anchors
but wait there's more you'll also get a
limited edition I infection as well as
backstage passes to my [ __ ] I know
right some things are too good to be
true and some things are just too good
on a personal note this job makes me
happier than a united states senator on
hooker Monday so which waiting for by
the issue the opinions expressed in this
issue exclusively those of the Prime
Minister of England
hey youtubers is charlie so backstage
passes to Deadpool's [ __ ] what could
be better than that I feel like this is
probably one of the best teasers they've
done aside from like a full-blown
trailer if you're confused about what
was going on with this you know in the
lead-up to some of the trails they've
been dropping they've been doing some
alternative marketing with teasers and
different outlets one of the awesome
things about the character is that he
breaks the fourth wall the time so it's
really easy for Ryan Reynolds to do
green screen promos like this what it's
selling though in case you don't buy
magazines like I'm not a big magazine
buyer myself either it was just a
Deadpool feature in the new empire
magazine it's just had a couple of these
new images they all look like they're
taken from that scene where negasonic
teenage warhead activates her powers and
takes Gina Carano down like a sack of
potatoes that's probably one of the best
scenes from that trailer actually here
I'll go ahead and play it again real
quick hey you're way too much dude for
me that's why I brought him I mean
that's why I brought her oh no finish
your tweet so that's fine just give us a
second go get her tiger oh I'm so pity
the dude who pressures her into prom sex
part of me wonders who wrote this promo
language though Kevin Sorbo Hercules
name-drop maybe that was ryan reynolds
himself he's a pretty funny guy on his
own how many of you guys rewound the
video when he said wolf semen like wait
a minute what's he cooking the full
transcripts of three of his worst movies
which actually that's a good question
which of Ryan Reynolds movies do you
think are his three worst I would
definitely say Green Lantern's on there
somewhere as a love the idea that he's
getting hard on people's tears I guess
that's a fanboy tears that he's talking
about usually usually they talk about
writers like george RR martin drinking
fanboy tears when he kills characters
that you love it kind of sounds like
he's trying to sell you an STD here you
go here's some hepatitis have some fun
with that there's got to be miles and
miles of outtakes from this it sounds
like most of its improved but but let me
know like what do you guys think about
promos like this versus just straight-up
teasers from the movie the problem with
teasers is that a lot of times they just
drop different versions of the exact
same footage I feel like these are way
more creative would you guys rather see
promos like this rather than you know a
bunch of trailers spoiling big plot
points in the movie I always give movies
bonus points whenever they try
alternative marketing like this think
back to Avengers age of Ultron whenever
that movie was getting ready to come out
they posted so much footage you base
saw the entire movie before the movie
came out this would actually be a really
easy workaround doing more stuff like
this where you have the actors in
character just doing things that the
characters would normally do just having
fun I guess it would only work for
certain characters like if you remember
the captain america movie the first
captain america movie where Steve Rogers
is selling war bonds that would be like
Marvel's captain america version of
something like this they should totally
try that I think it'd be awesome let me
know in the comments though do you want
to see more stuff like this even if it
has absolutely nothing to do with the
movie in related news they probably will
be dropping some more Deadpool footage
because you remember that movie is
coming out in February so we're almost a
month away from that dropping that's
really like the tip of the spear in
terms of superhero movies this year then
just movies TVs coming back a little bit
before that so let me know what kind of
Deadpool bonus videos you guys want me
to do in the meantime just in case you
guys didn't see it i posted a bunch of
Deadpool stuff during the holidays you
can click here for my playlist and you
can click your to learn all about the
big game of Thrones season 6 delay with
winds of winter thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you